uh hello
i'm adam schabonsky i'm a symbolic
algorithms developer at warframe
research
and today i will be talking about
symbolic optimization
so what's the global optimization
problem we are given
an objective function a set of
constraints
and domain specifications for the
variables
the variables can be either real or
integers
and constraints are constructed from
equations inequalities
region element statements using boolean
operators and quantifiers so some
variables can be
quantified and now what are the goals
want to find the global optimum infimum
or supremum
of values of f on the solution set of
constraints
so it's inferior supremum because it may
not always be attained so it's
some cases maximum or minimum if it's
attained
if possible so if the if the optimum is
attained we would like to
find the point satisfying the
constraints at which the optimum is
obtained
and if the function of the constraint
contain parameters we would like to find
parametric formulas for the optimum
value and optimum point
so i will talk
i will show
some of the algorithms that our global
optimization is using
in in recent few versions the the global
optimization capabilities have been
extended
and and they are being extended right
now so the future versions will
contain some some more methods for
global optimization i will talk about
this
as well so first you invariate
optimization so the most general
method is the analytic method so we
we would like to find all zeros of the
derivatives singular points and
limits and domain endpoints and this is
enough to
to find the global optimum
of any univariate functions
so for some classes of functions like
rational functions
x block functions or generally time
elementary functions so these are
elementary functions that do not have do
not contain
things like unrestricted trig
tricks of unrestricted arguments so so
they are guaranteed to have five number
of zeros
and we can find all those zeros and we
can find find
all singularities so this this class of
functions we have
complete solutions so for instance here
is an x block function
and we can minimize it we get solution
in terms of
transcendental root object so this this
root object actually
represents an exact number
which is a root of of the function
that's equal to
this approximation that is shown in the
last argument
and indeed if we plot the function we
can see that we have found
global minimum
for general real analytic functions we
can solve optimization problems over
bounded intervals so in general
functions may have infinitely many
zeros of the derivative or infinitely
many singular points so we are not able
to
find all of them in general but
a bounded interval we can solve the
optimization problem
here we get a message that maximize use
numeric integration
to show that the result is a global
maximum that means that we
wanted to count the roots of of the
derivative
and the only way we could count the
roots is by numeric integration because
the
symbolic integration contour integration
for this function would not succeed
and here's the exact result again and
we can show that indeed this is the
maximum
so what about other methods so we have a
class of methods using
periodicity so if
if a function is periodic it's
sufficient to solve the optimization
problem within a single period
so for instance here we have a function
the function itself is not periodic but
is a composition of
of periodic function with a function
that that
whose set of values includes a single
period so this is enough we
we then know that we can just optimize
the the outer function
over a single period and we
we can solve optimization problem again
we get
exact solution in terms of root objects
and here's the function it's somewhat
complicated discontinuous function but
we got the global optimum
now for combinations of periodic
functions
we can also say something so if we have
a combination of periodic functions with
incommensurable periods then the maximum
value
is not attained but we can still
figure out what the maximum value is
and here it is
and let's show the function
here is the maximum value indeed it's
not attained but but we get
arbitrarily close
and the same holds for
integer problems again if we have
combination of periodic functions with
incommensurable periods over the integer
we know how to find its optimum values
here's a minimum value over the integer
over their integers
and here's the plot again it's never
attained but
what is the infimum of values of the
function
other methods so here here is something
that was recently added methods using
function property information so so
mathematica now has information about
mathematical functions it has built in
so it knows the domain singularities
monotonicity limits
at domain endpoint local globe and
global minima
and more properties and this can be
properties can be used
to solve global optimization problems
for instance here we
have composition of c integral and dos
on f
and we have information about global
mean of dose on f and monotonicity of c
integral
so if if we know where where the global
minimum of the inner function is and we
know that
the outer function is increasing
then this must be the global max the
global minimum of the composition
and indeed it is the global
minimum
and here's another example that takes
makes use of the information about
global minima of vessel j
so as we can see bessel j has
infinitely many local minima and maxima
but we know that this first maximum is
is the global one
now to multivariate optimization
so multivariate optimization is much
harder
and the most general method that we have
is
bases on cylindrical algebraic
decomposition
so the advantage is it's
it applies to arbitrary polynomial
problems involving polynomial rational
functions or real algebraic functions
either in objective function or in
constraints
we so there are no convexity
requirements that are
usually important for for for instance
for numeric methods
no degree bounds constraints may involve
arbitrary quantifiers
there may be arbitrary parameters
involved and the method has no numerical
stability problems
well disadvantages there is one rather
big disadvantage it's doubly exponential
complexity in the number of variables so
unfortunately this method
can be applied to to very few variables
like three or four
and here are a couple of examples
so here we have example with two
variables and
two parameters and we get parametric
solution for
the maximum value and
the other example has
two variables and two quantified
variables
so we eliminate the two quantifiers and
optimize over
the three variables x y and here is the
minimum value which is a root object
so okay so so
suppose we don't have parameters or
quantifiers in the problem
and we are not re
we don't really require exact solution
is it always better to
to use numerical optimization not really
so so
numerical optimization algorithm and and
symbolic
optimization algorithms are are quite
different and they have
quite different strengths and weaknesses
so
[Music]
of course numeric optimization algorithm
is better if we if the functions are
non-polynomial or we have more variables
so these are weaknesses of the of the
symbolic algorithm but then
weaknesses of the numeric algorithms are
that if a problem is numerically
unstable
then the algorithm may fail
even though the problem may be very easy
for for the symbolic optimization
algorithm as well as if if the
constraints describe a cell a set that
is
very thin then
numeric algorithm may not find it the
constraints that
may not give the correct solution so
here here's an example we we take
a constraint that's constructed as a
product of
two quadratic polynomials one of them is
squared
and so here it is
the expanded constraint and we get
this solution and now we only change the
last digit
of the first number so it's the 21st
digit
and solve the maximization problem again
and as you can see the
the the solution is quite different
and it's it's in a quite different
place so the the maximum
even though the difference is in the
21st digit so
so certainly numerical algorithms which
uses
machine precision 16 digit numbers will
not work here
because for 16 digits precision
both inputs look exactly the same but
even if we
use high working precision so this i ran
with
1000 digits of working precision
it takes over almost half a minute and
as you can see it's it's a completely
different results it's on the order of
10 to the minus 10 and the real maximum
is on the order of
10 000 or is 100 000. so so it's it's
completely different scale completely
different place
so in this case hyper even high
precision doesn't
doesn't help and let's see why so
i well we cannot draw the actual set you
will see why
so instead of 10 billion here i just use
10
so it's a similar problem and and we
plot the
what the solution set is so so this is
the first set of constraints a very
small
disk and
a large radius
analous which which is very narrow
and now which we change the
so this is the adding the one to the
first chord
to to this first coefficient
so we just add x squared and what
happens with the solution set
well it's it becomes
quite different so it's it still has the
center disc but but there are
really small parts only of the outer
ring so and of course
in the actual problem that we used
before it was 10 billion rather than 10
so
this was really really narrow and
really small disc and really narrow ring
and and this were
like two small dots and of course the
numerical algorithm
it finds actually you can see i'm using
here an
internal cad plot which which uh
computes the plot by first locating the
solution set using
by computing symbolic synthetic
composition and then use this numeric
method to
to draw the the picture because if i use
region plot it would actually not not
find the
not find any solution for for this
okay so let's go to to other methods
so analytic methods so they are in some
sense
they are more general that called the
composition methods
so these are methods using lagrange
multipliers or
the kkt conditions
so we we could find all local extrema
then
pick the smallest or the largest local
extremum the
the thing is we have to check the
smoothness of objective functions as
smoothness and
non-degeneracy of the constraints and
that's that's that's a hard problem
and then we need to check for extrema on
the boundary
and extreme at infinity which which
again is is
a pretty hard and insolvable problem for
for most cases so what are advantages
well it can solve some transcendental
problems so
it can solve some problems that the
previous method could not solve
however they they have to lead to
systems of equations that mathematical
can solve which are
not that many for tr multivariate
transcendental equations
so disadvantages requires abilities to
solve
arbitrary systems of equations
inequalities so in general if we run
this algorithm
on algebraic problems for which the
previous method would apply
the equations we are getting will be
harder to solve than
than if we just run the the optimization
by cad algorithm
and so the implemented methods require
bonded
solution sets of constraints with simple
to compute boundaries
and finite set of stationary and
singular points
that's that's the that's the case
because we need to check the smoothness
we better have fire number singularities
and the finite number of local extrema
to be able to
to solve the problem so here's a couple
of examples
so here's an example that
has trigonometric functions of one
variable
and polynomials in the other variable
and
constraints are just a box here and a
constraint using the same
type of functions
trigonometry for one and polynomial for
the other and we can get the solution
and the other one is
we optimize x block function over over a
disk and we again get the solution
so more methods so special case methods
of course linear programming is one of
very important special case methods we
can solve much
problems with a much larger number of
variables but of course the objective
function and the constraints have to be
all linear so that's that's a
rather large restriction but as you can
see
10 variables almost no time and
very close algorithm
linear fractional programming so the
objective function can be a
ratio of linear functions and the
constraints have to be linear
and again problem with 10 variables no
time
and linear fractional programming
integer linear programming so now all
variables are
integers and the objective functions and
the constraints
are linear so here's a problem with
seven variables
and we well we also
need to make it bounded so the branch
and bond method that's used actually
can work the unbounded problems are
unsolvable
and well we got this solution for for
seven variables and it's
involves quite large integers as you can
see
so now some new
special case method so it's coming soon
for
evaluation of those i used
the development version so
multi-parametric linear programming what
is it
so the objective function is linear
and all constraints are linear in the
variables
and the parameters so we have a vector
of variables x and vector of parameters
t
and so the constraints as you can see
they they depend on the parameters
and let me show the result rather than
evaluate so
you know actually this problem could
have been solved with
the cylindrical decomposition method but
i
tried this one and and in five minutes
it doesn't return so
that that's because we have eight
variables you have six
variables and two parameters so for
cylindrical decomposition it's eight
eight variables for double exponential
algorithm that sort of hits the
the double exponential wall won't finish
with this special case algorithm we just
need
0.3 seconds and
here what the answer looks like
so it's the minimum value
is linear function piecewise linear
function
of parameters
and we could also get optimum
points as function as linear functions
of parameters and
the nice thing about the the algorithm
used here is that
the optimum point and the optimum value
are
continuous functions of parameters so
that's that's that's very important the
applications that this is used in
control and so so we really don't want
to have
jumps in in the optimum point solution
because
that would translate to jumps of some
physical
device and that would be bad
so let's see and this is plot
of of the domains of
of piecewise function of of the
constraints for each piece of piecewise
function so
on each on each of those polygons
we have a different formula for for the
solution
and here is the plot of the solution
so you can see it's is piecewise linear
and it's continuous
and now this the other algorithm is
where did it go
let me try okay so
multi-parametric quadratic programming
the objective function
is is now quadratic in x and
linear in t but but we can have
coefficients in t multipli t multiplied
by x
and we also require that this is a
positive definite matrix so
we make sure that this is for each value
of t
we get a convex quadratic function as
the objective function
and the constraints are as as before
they are linear and
in x and t
so here is an example here is the
quadratic function
the objective function and we have the
constraints which are linear in x
and t
and we can solve for minimum value in
0.56 seconds again this would be
solvable
theoretically by cylindrical
decomposition algorithm but but again it
takes a very long time
and here's the answer so
we get a piecewise function which is
piecewise quadratic
and these are the
linear linear sets so so
polygons are in general polyhedron in
parameters
so here's the picture we have different
values on
on all those polygons and
also on edges of the polygons and points
some of those conditions are lower
dimensional
and the the white spaces where
where there is no solution to the
constraints
and here is the plot of the answer
actually we get a nice smooth function
so this is a piecewise function but
piecewise quadratic function but when
you plot it you
just look smooth
so this is coming in the
future version of mathematica
okay so let me show some other methods
like
monotonic decomposition so now we since
we have information about monotonicity
of
vary of many of mathematical special
functions
well we can see that
this objective function is just the
composition of monotonic function with
with a polynomial so we can
maximize the the function
and here is the solution
and of course these are just algebraic
root objects because
eventually we you know after after
removing the monotonic functions we are
just optimizing the polynomial over
over polynomial condition
and here is another case so piecewise
subdivision
this is a piecewise function if you if
we want to
to optimize a piecewise function we just
optimize it
separately each piece over over the
condition so this will optimize sine
over
the set where psi is greater than cosine
optimize cosine over the set where
cosine is greater than sine and
so here is the solution and
this we can plot so here is
this is say so this combines
this combines the periodicity with with
piecewise
subdivision so we just need to
optimize within a single period and with
within the single period we have a
piecewise function
and there are many other methods that
are did not mention
but so there are various heuristics that
that may work in some cases
and that's all thank you for listening
and if you have any questions i
will try to answer them now
okay i see first question are lagrange
multipliers
only used when there are bounce on the
variables
right now yes yes right right now yes
because we
we have to have the control over the the
boundary
of the set so there are other cases with
that that we may
develop in the future like for instance
if we are able to to
prove that the objective function is is
convex
then then we can allow
the case which is completely uh
unrestricted variables
so so that there are possibly
improvements to that
but right now they are using only when
they are bound on the variables
uh oh there is a question will i post
the note for this talk yes i i
will post it and i see that
olek is raising hand could somebody a
mute oleg
uh i
i only have a button to ask
when can the new functions be expected
so they are they are not uh
going to be in the nearest version the
one that that's being released right now
the version 12.2 but
they they should be in the next next
three so probably in in about six months
i would say
okay so since i see no questions thank
you very much again for for attending
the talk and
i will stop here
you